(lighthearted music)
- I've never had pizza
with sprinkles on it.
- I don't think I'd like that
because in England,
it's weird to put sweet
and savory together.
- That sounds okay.
I mean like, I'm not
gonna like not try it.
(ding)
- Thank you so much.
- Oooh.
- Looks like you did this accidentally.
- This seems confusing.
This is like a dream sequence.
- I'm gonna take an instagram of this.
It's so pretty.
- Cake and pizza.
- My mouth is very confused.
- You, no, you get this sprinkle
in the back of your teeth,
so I have sprinkles in
the back of my teeth,
and I'm mad at you for that.
- Obviously I like pizza with sprinkles.
- I don't know how it would be if you had,
like pepperoni and other things on top.
- My mouth is separating the pepperoni
and the pineapple and the normal food
from the sprinkles right now.
- I just got chills.
- A five year old and a stoned person
i feel have eerily similar kitchen ideas.
And I don't hate it.
(mumbles)